ex vicepresidente de Donald Trump y
posible precandidato presidencial por el
partido republicano las próximas
elecciones testificó por más de cinco
horas ante un gran Jurado en Washington
sobre lo que pasó después de las
elecciones presidenciales del 2020 y las
acciones de Trump que llevaron a la toma
al Capitolio según medios nacionales
penns estaba citado para describir los
detalles de las conversaciones que tuvo
con el expresidente Trump El Seis de
enero del 2021 en las que supuestamente
son presionó apenas para que
desconociera y bloqueara los resultados
de las pasadas elecciones presidenciales
las declaraciones de penn se vienen
después de que Trump haya tratado hasta
el miércoles en la noche de bloquear
esta testificación por parte de su ex
vicepresidente ante el gran Jurado y en
medio de una campaña para la nominación
republicana para enfrentar al partido
demócrata en las próximas elecciones del
2024 recordemos que el entonces
vicepresidente Mike pence que actuaba
como presidente del senado se negó a
seguir las demandas de Trump diciendo
que él tenía que seguir la Constitución
Aunque creyera que había fraude
electoral